Fox News has obtained more text messages
from those anti-trump lovers at the FBI
agents who were investigating his
campaigns possible ties to Russia on
election day Lisa page writes oh my god
this is terrifying Peter struck replies
oh my god I am so depressed
later that month Paige wrote I got all
the President's Men figure I need to
brush up on Watergate the texts are
raising even more questions about what
the FBI and former President Obama knew
about the Clinton investigation and when
in one newly obtained message Paige
writes about preparing talking points
for FBI director James Comey saying
POTUS wants to know everything we're
doing didn't mr. Obama once insists he
never got involved in FBI investigations
I do not talk to the Attorney General
about pending investigations I do not
talk to FBI directors about pending
investigations they we have a strict
line and always have maintained it for
presidents just to button this up I
guarantee it you I guarantee that there
is no political influence in any
investigation conducted by the Justice
Department or the FBI not just in this
case but in any case and she will all
stop . . dana period so it could look
terrible or it could be that he was
seeking a briefing about the russia
involvement and meddling in the election
from these text messages we we don't
know that you could also be briefed and
not try to weigh in if you're concerned
about russia involvement because
remember the DNC was saying we were
hacked the Russians did this and I'm
sure that he wanted to say something one
of the critics criticisms of President
Obama from Democrats is that he did not
do enough talking about Russian meddling
in the election and if this was really
about the Moller probe well there would
be one thing to know we don't know that
and if it's about Hillary's email
scandal and if President Obama wanted to
squash it
he wasn't very effective because 10 days
before the election is when James Comey
sends the
back up to Congress that says by the way
I'm reopening the Hillary email
investigation case if you remember
Hillary Clinton in her book and not just
in her book but in all of her interviews
blames James Comey for her loss to
President Trump so I'm not exactly sure
what's going on here
all right Jessie do you have any clarity
in your mind I wish I did I'd like to
know more they should be testifying up
on Capitol Hill this may be the first
clue though we have of President Obama
possibly being involved in the FBI
shenanigans if he wants to know what the
FBI is up to is it about the Hillary
investigation that was closed at the
time this text was sent is it about the
Trump Russian Weiner investigation not
at that point that was the 28th this was
the 2nd of September was it about the
Trump Russia investigation we we don't
know that either if it was about the DNC
hack you want to know about that they
never even got the DNC server from the
Democrats he never handed it over so
that's suspicious even answered a call
never even answered the calls Trump I
mean Obama says you know he doesn't
comment on pending investigations he
commented on the Hillary investigation
on camera he said that never jeopardize
national security actually Comey then
contradicted himself and said it did
jeopardize national security he waited
on the IRS probe when that was pending
said it was you know just a few
hooligans in the Cincinnati office you
know what it was more than that because
Lois Lerner took the fifth you have also
text messages saying we have to focus on
the task at hand
what are these anti-trump FBI agents
talking about what's the task at hand if
they're so terrified about the election
of President Trump does it have anything
to do with the insurance policy that
they hatched in the Department of
Justice's office I'd like to know about
that that's why they should testify
they're also talking about a phone they
have where they're talking about Hillary
Clinton's investigation that we can't
talk on this phone
where'd that phone go I'd like to see
that phone maybe they smash it with a
hammer like Hillary there Trump haters
and their snobs because they referred to
Republican voters in Virginia as
ignorant hillbillies and they're also
Comey loyalists and they love him to
death we've seen those texts and they
hate congressional oversight they were
besmirching the Republican Congress
there's also a wide gap to which was
variance
so on the 28th of September 2016 they
discovered these Huma and Hillary emails
on weiners laptop a whole month passed
before Comey comes out and he says he
was just briefed on the new emails they
discovered what happened in that month
I'd like to know that people suspect
McCabe who was ushered out by
Christopher Rea may have something to do
with delaying that we're going to find
out sooner or later but the bottom line
is that it's clear now that these Trump
hating FBI agents were on an anti-trump
mission and President Obama may be
involved yeah that's really funny
I think you know at some point Jesse
it's like you know they talk about fog
of war this is a fog of foolishness okay
because it's obvious the President and
Dana picked up on this Democrats are
upset the President Obama did not do
enough in terms of the Russian
interference that he and the
intelligence agencies had confirmed was
taking place during the 2016 election
okay
the idea that the FBI should be briefing
the president on Russian interference
it's not far-fetched that that makes
sense that he briefed does this because
the circumstances the timing is exactly
right not only that the Wall Street
Journal has an article out today and it
says text from the 2016 preparation show
preparation to brief Barack Obama about
Russian interference in that year's
election sure rant and rave on this show
I let you have the floor but Jesse it at
some point
don't you think it would be good instead
of always throwing up conspiracy
theories to try to defend the
indefensible Donald Trump you might come
with some facts you've been calling this
whole thing a conspiracy for the last
year yet every time facts come out it
proves you wrong who give me some facts
on everything I said about Hillary's
probe was oh my gosh please yes wait no
don't bring Obama into it just on this I
don't bring them into the text message
it's part of the elements for tonight's
show these everybody knows what this is
about
exceptin the russia probe or the trump
surveillance yes we don't know today
Eric Holder at a breakfast meeting said
President Obama never contacted him
about any invent any FBI investigate all
trust errors I can throw did we just
play a clip of President Obama saying he
doesn't get involved in FBI
investigation well whether it's about
Donald Trump or the Russian
investigation he's involved right no he
never he's asking tell me what's going
on with the Russians trying to influence
an American election that is a you're
putting words in the text oh I see
okay the watch make journalists to I
guess the thing is that with every
bombshell it's like we're getting
shell-shocked because no one is a
bombshell every time a new information
comes out the more texts come out we
forget about the last ones I always
think that the best references in these
stroke a page texts have to do with
Hillary you know when this on September
28th you were talking about the you know
the Andy's office meeting he said you
know new emails came out to Huma and
weiner emails came out and he says
stroke says will this ever end struck
will this never end he's he's dying to
wrap up this Hillary thing and you go
back five months before when he says
when Trump was the it was gonna be the
nominee remember when when when Cruz
dropped out and Trump was gonna be the
nominee they were going crazy on the
text I can't believe it oh my gosh Trump
is gonna be the nominee and now the
pressure starts to finish the NYE
we know what that is the Hillary
investigation he was trying to wrap up
that Hillary investigation and want
that's your evidence it's all over the
place bring in the jury
I will stand and I'm ready to lecture
the jury there are so many incriminating
texts in this structure right about one
thing what's that it will never end yeah
18:1 thing it does go back to over and
over again this is decision by Hillary
Clinton and her team that allowed her to
do it including the White House that
allowed her to have a private server a
separate set of circumstances emails
that got destroyed wiped up from the
server these guys end up talking about
that you know they're having their
affair and talking about business and
investigations on their government
phones this is the unsexy of the fairway
did they talk about anything did you a
lot of it was redacted right was there
like I don't know did you read the whole
thing one point he says is it okay for
me to send you some pictures we don't
pretty sure we know what is but Tom just
because we have two lovers who are
sending I mean it's unbelievable how
many emails they sent right yeah a
thousand it doesn't mean that you can't
have personal opinions it does it's more
than that people keep saying that it's
just people with the pious they can put
it aside they can't put it aside he's
gonna be President I'm losing my mind
exclamation point it's unbelievable
we've got to do something very
incriminating Election Day 2016 there
are people in this building speaking if
they were trying to stop something they
were very ineffective because again
commis letter ten days before the
election is what so many Democrats point
to as the point where they saw a lot of
independent women support drop in all of
the key states it should've dropped more
if he didn't change the wording away I
know win anyway but our guy stroke right
it's fast truck changed the words he
changed it from what's the words Jesse
from extremely negligent to oops I you
know yeah we went down planned so it
would have dropped even more if he
didn't talk about when a Comey was
speaking in July not in September early
October what I want to tell you guys
about this other memo they dropped last
night this Grassley memo now this is
really interesting one I'd like to hear
your defense on this so
make your the throny Sid Blumenthal yeah
she was now he was feeding anti-trump
smears through the Obama State
Department and it wound up in Chris
Steele's dossier now Christopher
Steele's dossier was based on we know on
two things Russian government sources
and Syd Blumenthal's lies the FBI also
knew that the Christopher Steele had
been lying and had been leaking to the
press about this yet they still used the
dossier and they still used Steele's
credibility to the FISA Court to present
that as justification for spying on the
Trump associates why would the FBI do
that why would they hide the funding
from the judge why did they deceive me
get tired we got trey Gowdy on this and
I'm gonna ask you to give you a reaction
one okay when you hear who the source of
one of the sources of that information
is you're going to think oh my gosh I've
heard that name somewhere before where
could it possibly have been and a fine
source the domestic source and I'm
trying to think how Secretary Clinton to
find him I think she said he was an old
friend who emailed her from time to time
I'd be really warm if you're warm yeah I
don't get it I don't get why you think
that this is somehow an indictment of
the Steele dossier or the investigation
I would hope that you would have every
source available if you are trying to
get information about how the Russians
are trying to influence our elections
potentially colluding with a source of
the dossier was a Hilary crony Russian
Liars in the Russian gossip here's the
thing so do you think that's a goal to
present to a judge to see it's not
verified the judge you do that yes you
are though you're not you cannot present
unverified information your FISA judge
Jessie slow down man I mean just let me
talk first thing you might learn
something okay but clearly the judge was
told that the source of the dossier was
a political partisan
the job under staring weather no they're
running it against it's true wasn't true
yours it was true what was true about
the dossier I'm not getting into that
here but I will you know what we know
about today one this day with this
business about the FBI lovers in there
you guys are so desperate how undermine
robert muller you'll do anything
Republicans will put on blinders he's
not been able to proffer one fact
forward that was accurate or true in the
dossier to support that if you weren't
slacking any kind of Oh about the
Russians interfered in our presidential
election well and that's one thing that
last night in the interview is that
regardless of the dossier there would
have been an investigation about Russian
meddling in the election but the other
thing I want to say about the Grassley
memo that you mentioned that kind of
irritates me about the Nunez memo that
apparently remember I made this whole
big thing about how you shouldn't take a
yahoo news article in to convince the
judge that there's there's corroboration
well in the Grassley memo it says it
wasn't used for corroboration that that
Yahoo news article so I feel like I'm
you know I get I get cautious about
commenting on all of this because it's
cherry-picked information it's not cut
you mean it's the Grassley memo says
that the Yahoo News article derived from
steel was used to corroborate steel but
that is not why the article was
referenced the Grassley memo appears to
confirm that was not presented for the
purpose of corroborate there's a
contradiction therefore I know they did
present it alongside the dossier a deep
I'm gonna I'll be calm one I'll be calm
I'll be friendly
it's dirty it's dirty it's dirty its
dirty what I think Peter stocks gonna
start sending text to Jessie little love
notes
they both be eager span and steal one
yep and I'll bleach them you guys can
continue this witty repartee during the
bridge